[Music]
foreign
good morning and welcome to Sky News
breakfast leading labor figures are
lining up to criticize the government
after Boris Johnson's resignation as an
MP the deputy leader Angela Rayner says
it's a never-ending Tori soap opera Mr
Johnson accused Those Behind the party
gate inquiry are trying to drive him out
meanwhile the Privileges committee has
accused the former PM of attacking the
Integrity of parliament Liz Bates
reports
and he's off Boris Johnson who nine
months ago was prime minister has quit
as an MP in a long angry statement he
blamed the Privileges committee that
investigated him over partygate
the evidence I shall give for this
committee shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth on
learning they wanted to see him
suspended for over 10 days which could
have seen him kicked out of the commons
he stood down branding it a kangaroo
court he thrives on the oxygen of
publicity so what on Earth he'll do next
I do not know so in some ways I don't
care but I do actually because I care
passionately about having people
involved in politics that are decent and
honest and honorable and don't tell lies
that is not that man Boris Johnson it
comes amid a standoff with the cabinet
office over their handling of his covid
Communications and his resignation
honors list added to the controversy
with his old Ally Nadine Doris denied a
peerage also dramatically standing down
just hours earlier I'd done um you know
18 years as an MP and I did think I'd be
retiring in two years but this is kind
of New Life opening up in front of me
along with a granddaughter and so there
are just other priorities and things to
do and I was I didn't want to cause a
by-election but
but you know I've got over myself
frankly in his statement he takes aim at
the current prime minister his record on
brexit and his party's lack of ambition
and things are about to get worse for
Rishi sunak with a by-election now on
the horizon that could inflict another
electoral wound on the conservatives in
his seat of Uxbridge and ruislip
probably hate him as a prime minister
but he's quite funny as a person not the
best primers they're like everything
that he's done thus far is just
a bit
wrong and I mean whatever wrong that you
do you gotta face the consequences at
the end of the day there was only so
much he could say to get himself out of
trouble and to be honest for you we
needed someone fresh here in Uxbridge
all of this a gift to the opposition
it's a support Pro what the public want
to know about is who is going to look
after their interests who's going to be
actually interested in in in the cost of
living in looking after all hospitals in
making sure that we fight crime on our
streets that's what should be important
in the final line of his statement Mr
Johnson says he's going at least for now
a message reminiscent of his last words
in the Commons as prime minister
a reminder to his Rivals he may be
leaving Parliament but Boris Johnson's
influence on British politics is not
going anywhere Liz Bates Sky News
Westminster
foreign well as we mentioned Labor's
Deputy leader Angela Rayner is amongst
those piling in on the former PM this
morning she said the British public are
sick to the back teeth of this
never-ending Tory soap opera played out
at their expense after 13 years of
conservative chaos enough is enough it's
time to turn the page with a fresh start
for Britain with a labor government
focus on people's priorities of tackling
the cost of living and building a better
future
what is good like to Westminster our
political correspondent Rob Powell is
there for us this morning hi there Rob
so what happens next both procedurally
but also for Boris Johnson himself yeah
I think in the short term Anna there'll
be a nervous weight in government this
weekend for any evidence of more panic
in the party or the contagion spreading
if you like at the moment despite rumors
of more resignations among Boris Johnson
allies those haven't materialized allies
and friends of his like the newly nobled
Dame pretty Patel paying tribute calling
Boris Johnson a Titan of politics rather
than falling on her sword this weekend
then I think we wait for that full
privileges committee report to come out
potentially in the first part of next
week the Privileges committee released a
Punchy statement last night accusing
Boris Johnson of impugning the Integrity
of the house they said they'll meet on
Monday and conclude the inquiry and
publish shortly after that ever the
journalist Boris Johnson has tried to
write the first draft of history in his
resignation letter yesterday we wait to
read that report for ourselves then
there are the by-elections Boris
Johnson's old constituency in West
London clearly at risk Nadine dory's
potentially at risk her constituency
potentially at risk as well in the
longer term it then depends on what
Boris Johnson decides to do does he
decide on trying to stand again in
another seat I think there are problems
there does Rishi sunak and Tori HQ allow
that is he able to given that the
standards and the Privileges committee
report will still be hanging over his
head I think if he does stay on the
outside actually this could prove
positive for ishi sunak in the longer
term as it could stem the flow of drama
and finally banish the ghost of his
predecessor
yes an interesting one to watch and a
busy week Rob thanks very much indeed
well coming up I'll be speaking to Boris
Johnson's former press secretary will
Walden that's coming up around half or
seven and then at Tempo say the
conservative pier and pollster Lord
Hayward will give his take on what the
former PM's resignation could mean for
the Tories of the next general election
and then at 10 past 9 we'll hear the
thoughts of the former Tory Justice
secretary David gorg So plenty of
reaction throughout the program this
morning
but now for an incredible Story of
Survival from the heart of the Colombian
jungle four children have been found
alive in the Amazon ending a five-week
search that gripped the country after
their plane crashed three adults died
when the plane went down due to engine
failure the four children aged 13 9 4
and 11 months survived the impact
well they were rescued close to the
crash site after spending 40 days alone
in the jungle Rescuers had previously
found discarded fruit that the children
ate to survive as well as improvised
shelters made with vegetation
Colombia's president Gustavo Petro
predicted their story would go down in
history
the first news is that indeed the
indigenous communities participating in
the search along with the Colombian
military have found the four children
after 40 days they were alone it was
them who achieved a great exemplary
survival
it will become history these children
are today the Children of Peace and the
children of Colombia
the details of the 37 Federal criminal
charges facing former U.S president
Donald Trump have been made public as
that unraveled we spotted the former
president playing golf our U.S
correspondent Mark Stone reports
spotted by Sky News on his golf course
Donald Trump teeing off just an hour
before the extraordinary indictment
against him was unsealed for all to see
37 felony counts federal charges laid
out over 49 pages and with photographs
the boxes containing the top secret
documents at the heart of all this found
at Trump's Mar-A-Lago Resort in a
bathroom in a store room in a ballroom
now we know what they're related to
the classified documents Trump stored in
his boxes included information regarding
defense and weapons capabilities of both
the United States and foreign countries
United States nuclear programs potential
vulnerabilities of the United States and
its allies to military attack and plans
for possible retaliation in response to
foreign attack
we can see the case for obstruction Mr
Trump has alleged to have told his
attorney to inform the FBI that he did
not have documents it alleges there was
the moving of documents to conceal them
and Mr Trump is alleged to have
suggested to his attorney that he hide
or destroy documents
then details of a recording between
Trump and a publisher
Trump showed and described a plan of
attack that Trump said was prepared for
him by the Department of Defense and a
senior military official Trump told the
individuals that the plan was highly
confidential and secret Trump also said
as president I could have Declassified
it and now I can't you know but this is
still a secret
that last point is alleged to have taken
place here at his New Jersey golf course
in July 2021 months after he had lost
the presidency and crucially it appears
to contradict his defense that he had
somehow Declassified the documents it
appears to prove that he knew he had
retained secret documents
Jack Smith is the independent special
counsel in this case he tasked a grand
jury of ordinary Americans to examine
the evidence They concluded there is a
case for Mr Trump to answer are laws
that protect National Defense
information are critical to the Safety
and Security of the United States
and they must be enforced
violations of those laws put our country
at risk
Mr Trump's defense for now is deflection
a boxer's hoax just like the Russia
Russia Russia hoax and all of the others
this has been going on for seven years
that they can't stop because it's
election interference at the highest
level there's never been anything like
what's happened I'm an innocent man I'm
an innocent person
this will test America politically
legally socially remember he is Far and
Away the favorite to be the Republican
candidate for the presidency his
supporters and many in his party too
seem to be locking in behind him against
what they believe is a conspiracy to
bring him down Mark Stone Sky News in
New Jersey
now parts of England could get hotter
than Ibiza today with the Met Office
warning that we could see temperatures
of up to 30 degrees well our
correspondent Aisha zaheed joins us now
from the Thames Lido in reading and
morning to you it's going to get really
hot and a challenge for some people to
to keep cool and safe
yeah that's absolutely right the scene
behind me might be a bit deceiving it's
quite quiet here but no doubt it's going
to pick up here Parks Beach is all
expected to be busy across England today
it's expected to reach about 31 degrees
across Central and Southern parts of
England and it's led to this Amber heat
Health alert issued by the UK Health
Security Agency now to be really clear
here the message isn't to stay cooped up
indoors by all means people should go
outside and enjoy the sunshine as much
as they want to but this health alert
has been put into place to remind people
to do so responsibly to so what it means
is that there is a danger of this heat
to people of all ages and of all ages
which means that the NHS could face some
strain as a consequence but um the
message they're really putting out is
people to stay hydrated to make sure
they're checking in on friends and
family as they normally would but
especially those who are elderly or more
vulnerable people with lung conditions
like asthma and these kind of wet this
kind of weather are more vulnerable it
exacerbates those symptoms so really
messages for people to enjoy the
sunshine but stay safe while doing so
Aisha thanks very much indeed well let's
get more on that warning with Skype
meteorologist Joe Wheeler and Joe tell
us just how hot is it likely to get and
what's behind this hot weather
we're looking at temperatures up to
around 30 31 degrees Celsius and that
zone most likely to see those high
temperatures is really London up to
Manchester and uh and then back down
towards the the southeast parts of Wales
as well so um yeah a lot of heat around
now of course we've had high pressure
over us for quite a long time and West
in the parts of the country have seen
some lovely Sunshine um parts of Wales
have seen high temperatures for the past
two weeks or so but here on the East
Coast it has been so cold I can't tell
you literally daytime temperatures 11 or
12 degrees Celsius and this is down to
an easterly drift which has brought low
cloud in over the coast and bringing it
Inland overnight and then it's not
burning back through the day so this is
virtually the first time we've seen
sunshine at all and of course
temperatures will respond in kind and
because these temperatures here today 10
degrees higher than we've seen over the
past couple of weeks uh of course there
was a heat alert out today that's for
the high temperatures but also a
thunderstorm warning and where you catch
one of those it could be potent to
rental rain in Dusty winds and even some
hail
okay Joe thanks very much indeed um so
another hot day on the card let's get a
look at the rest of the weekend's
forecast then
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
so that very warm air is moving up from
the south this weekend but it comes with
a risk of thunderstorms there may be a
few sharp showers in parts of Ireland
and Southwest Britain first thing but
for most it'll be a dry start if rather
cloudy towards North Sea coasts
overnight Cloud will slowly burn back to
the coast to leave plenty of sunshine
and very high UV levels it'll turn
increasingly hot and humid triggering
some heavy and thundering showers with
hail and and lightning Northeastern
Coast will be breezier and cooler with a
low Cloud lingers
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
now the UN Aid Chief is warning that a
staggering a 700 000 people in Ukraine's
Curson region are without access to
clean drinking water after the
destruction of the Nova kakovka Dam
well the UN Aid Chief warns of that huge
number of facing those challenges
without fresh water meanwhile
um
Kiev and Moscow have traded blame for
the explosion that sent 18 cubic
kilometers of water flooding across the
region the contaminated water is also
sparking fears of Cholera keeping misery
on an area already scarred by War
the figures are already terrifying we're
talking about 700 000 people without
proper drinking water that's an
extraordinary number the truth of this
is that this is only the beginning of
seeing the consequences of this act and
the consequences are going to be a
ravaged Bread Basket as you know
in that southern part of Ukraine and
that leads on to International
consequences
well that warning came as President
Putin repeated claims that a Ukrainian
counter-offensive has begun an operation
he says so far has failed to inflict any
real damage
first of all we can clearly say that the
offensive has started as indicated by
the use of strategic reserves by the
Ukrainian Army that's the first thing
secondly the Ukrainian troops haven't
achieved their stated tasks in a single
area of fighting this is absolutely
obvious
well for more on all this I'm joined by
our military analyst Sean Bell nice to
see you Sean morning to you and so first
of all this warning from the UN AIDS
Chief about the number of huge number of
people affected uh by not being able to
get access to fresh water potentially
after this destruction of this key Dam
yeah it's it's huge numbers I mean the
environmental impact the impact on
people the sewage everything there's
huge amounts and it's worth remembering
that this Dam wasn't just there for a
show it wasn't just there to provide a
road it provided fresh drinking drinking
water for a whole load of people it was
a hydroelectric Dam which provided a
huge amounts of power
um and also provide the cooling water
for the zapreach and nuclear facility
now we pretty confident that's not going
to be a problem but as you say the one
the long-term impacts this Dam blowing I
think what's interesting though you know
excuse me but from a military
perspective you know clearly there's a
horrible there's several people that
died as a result of the dam blowing but
actually it's really interesting because
the immediate impact on the war is more
that suddenly Russia protects a flank
you can't do an amphibious assault
across the genepro because it's all
flooded and that reduces the front line
that Russia has to worry about and also
gives a bit of Carnage for Ukraine to
distract them from their main effort but
actually it's uh the dam if the Russians
have blown the dam when the ukrainians
had been doing uh an amphibious approach
that could have been devastating and
also so one of the reasons that the
ukrainians would have been worried about
it because they'd have been worried that
Russia might have blown that now they've
blown it
the waters will recede I understand
actually the dam Waters already started
to fall and therefore the the flood
waters will recede and when they do
we're in the summer months there's less
rainfalls all of a sudden that in April
will once again be affordable they will
be able to do attacks across it without
the threat of the Russians blowing the
dam so in a way
um Ukraine will have known this down was
was set with demolition charges to blow
they will therefore are planned
accordingly now Russia has blown it that
takes that card off the table so it will
be interesting in the weeks and and
months ahead that once again will make
life a little bit more difficult for
Russia in the long term than it does in
the near term and we've been talking for
weeks about a spring offensive by
Ukraine President Putin is now saying
that's counter-offensive has begun
already is he right in that analysis
well every time we comment on President
Putin we always take a large dollop of
salt with it
um the very fact if you look at the
context of why he said it has started he
said because the Russian defenses have
been so robust we've inflicted Dreadful
casualties and in other words it was
sort of a Victorious uh sense the harsh
reality of it is that we've been waiting
for this spring offensive for some time
um we all expect a sort of fan pair of
trumpets as everybody rushes across the
start line there's normally a couple of
phases beforehand the first one is you
prepare by targeting the rear of your
enemy the logistics chain the railway
intersections we've seen that been
happening over the last few weeks the
next phase is you do all on the front
you probe defenses and to see where the
Russian defenses are weakest and where
you and then you capitalize with
momentum we've not seen the major thrust
yet of the Ukrainian forces and it's
worth pointing out president zielinski
said
um you'll know when our
counter-offensive has started because
Russia will feel it I don't think
Russia's feeling it yet and I think
these are the opening overtures that
we're seeing
um there has been some reports of
Western tanks being destroyed much of
which this limited detail because
Ukraine are not talking about it at all
at the moment but I suspect we're going
to hear more more about over the coming
days but we're going to be really
cautious about reading too much in to
the odd sound bites we're getting out at
the moment well absolutely because you
have to remember it's an information War
as well and Ukraine won't want to give
away any of its Secrets will it of its
strategy but there is a challenge for
Russia isn't there and where they put
their troops because they don't know
where Ukraine might strive exactly right
and what Russia will be holding is some
forces in reserves and waiting to see if
the Ukraine's make any breakthrough and
plug in the gaps I think this what's
fascinating though from a military
perspective and again you'll excuse me
looking is from a purely military
perspective Russia will it's a
superpower and we are in the west we've
given lots of equipment and Aid to
Ukraine and we're sort of hoping that
Ukraine will roll back Russia there'll
be a huge victory that might happen but
we also have to remember that Russia's
had weeks indeed months to prepare its
defenses it's got huge resources
available to it and it is possible that
Russia will actually stem their tide and
Ukraine will suffer three times the
casualties in offense that the Russians
do on defense this could end up with
Ukraine getting bloody nose and in the
worst case the Russians could roll them
back and that would have devastating
consequences for the future of the war
president zelensky and the West support
these things hang on a knife edge it'll
be really I think we've got to be really
careful not to just expect the Russians
to be rolled back to roll back we hope
that's what will happen but it'll be
very fraught and I no doubt zlensky is
not sleeping well at night at the moment
no and it could go on for a very long
time absolutely right yeah Sean thanks
very much indeed thank you
now a Florida researcher who broke the
record for the longest stretch a human
has spent living under water has
resurfaced after 100 days diving
Explorer and medical researcher Dr
Joseph detouri known online as Dr deep
sea spent over three months living nine
meters underwater in the jewels undersea
Lodge in Key Largo in Florida his
mission combines medical and ocean
research to study how the human body
responds to long-term explosion exposure
to extreme pressure
let's get more reaction now to Boris
Johnson's resignation and what it can
mean for his political future joining me
now is the former press secretary to
Boris Johnson will Walden very good
morning to you thanks so much for
talking to us and you've worked very
closely with Boris Johnson what do you
make of his resignation and the way in
which he's done it
oh I it's not in the least bit
surprising to me I mean Boris Johnson
cares about one thing and that's winning
or at least not losing and he hasn't
lost an election since being rejected by
the voters of clue itself back in 1997
and I think the thing for Boris was that
clearly this report threatened to change
all that he's clearly seen the writing
on the wall and presumably a lengthy
common suspension was coming his way
that would mean a by-election in his
marginal constituency and probably
defeating that election and and Boris
Johnson won't let that stand that's the
primary motivation here protecting his
version of The Narrative and by going as
he has all guns blazing he's able to
avoid defeat and blame pretty much
everyone else for his demise the
committee Sue gray Rishi sunak and
frankly from the statement anyone
seemingly who voted remain in 2016. but
yet breathtaking as the statement is
it's also so Boris and in many ways it's
not the least bit surprising he told the
committee if they found him guilty he
wouldn't respect the outcome and and
there we go so it's proved his marriage
for the last year has been I've done
nothing wrong you know his two speeches
when he left office one when he resigned
one when he finally went they tell you
all you need to know and it's been
repeated in the statement yesterday it's
all about it's not me gov it's someone
else and that's all very deliberate I
think what's happened here is that by
resigning he's forever able to say I
delivered brexit I want a huge majority
and yet those pescetory MPS did me over
and now some biased committee has pushed
me out all to stop brexit now that is
largely Hokum but there it is it's very
Boris
well yes and his criticism is Extreme
isn't it of the committee as you say he
repeats that he's done nothing wrong he
talks about the committee's report being
riddled with inaccuracy wreaking of
privilege Prejudice he talks about an
absurd and unjust process he talks about
a political hit job a Witch Hunt a
kangaroo court all of that in the same
statement are you surprised then that
with that kind of fight behind him that
he's not standing up to defend himself
in front of MPS or potentially at a
by-election he's not fighting on not not
in the slightest because he he knows
he's probably going to lose and as I
said he he doesn't do lose and what's I
think what's extraordinary about the
statement none of this as I say is a
surprise but the statement itself is a
new level of kind of borisism in that
sense so you know he's clearly angry and
he's convinced of his own truth and his
own righteousness there's no apology no
taking responsibility and it is very
trumpian and what's interesting is Boris
hates the comparisons with Trump but it
is the language of Vendetta it's a long
rant and you know frankly it's deeply
misleading in places but it it's very
Boris and he knows all this he knows a
lot of what he's saying is is not true
but I think that there's also a large
part of him that actually believes he
really has been hard done by and in part
I think that's because of you know if he
didn't the facade of all this would
crumble but I think in part it's because
I suspect all those around him are
pulling in the same direction as him and
saying the same things to him I think
for me the sad thing this morning is
that I don't really recognize that
person compared to the Johnson that I
work for you know I think he is a
different person there's a there's a
bitterness there's a pettiness there's
no sense of proportion and you know it's
just not him
you know when I worked for him at City
Hall you know he was always the first to
laugh at himself he could be
self-deprecating he did listen but but
he's changed and thinking about this
Hannah this morning I'll give you one
quick example famously he wrote two
opposing columns ahead of the brexit
referendum and everyone accused him of
opportunism then but actually that was
the thoughtful Boris you know balancing
the arguments in his own head I think it
would be impossible to think of him
having that political antenna now
instead it seems to me he sees things
only through the prism of sort of anger
and hurt and unfairness and and for me
as someone that knew him well
encountered him as a friend for many
years I think that's sad I think that's
tragic but I think it's also quite
dangerous
and the Privileges committee seems
pretty angry at themselves they've
issued a statement saying that Boris
Johnson has impuged the Integrity of the
house by this statement there's quite
strong staff isn't it yeah it is and
it's not surprising because you know
he's certainly impuned them in his in
his response and they will presumably
move very quickly to deal with this and
publish the full report and present
their evidence and then there'll be
those that hate Johnson who'll say Told
You So and those who love him will say
what a load of all old rubbish but I
think what's important is if he was
thinking about some sort of political
comeback particularly now and there are
clearly some in the Tory party who are
worried about the possibility of him
standing down now but seeking a safe
seat in a by-election or ahead of the
next you know ahead of the next election
I think that's not going to happen but
but clearly you know the committee will
have seen the way he's responded and and
and they will perhaps want to you know
go even further um you know given that
he's responded in the way he has to the
report maybe there'll be further
sanction as a result of this so he he is
upped the stakes massively but on the
other hand what's he got to lose in that
regard if they were going to publish
this anyway he's got the first strike in
he's tried to take control of the
steering wheel of the car
um regardless of where it's going to end
up crashing so you don't think he'll
make a comeback and try and stand again
certainly in the short term but how much
damage can he do from the sidelines I
mean the statement is full of Digs at
Rishi sunak and his government isn't it
will he carry on with those kind of
attacks do you think and will they will
they strike home
yeah he'll see me carry on with him I I
suspect I I suspect there's number 10
and quite a few Taurean bees will be
hoping that without an elected platform
he'll kind of wander aimlessly Into the
Wilderness eventually I think that's a
big hope and I don't think it'll
materialize I think it's worth
remembering only a few weeks ago he was
being written off again the local
election results didn't kill off soon
act his Insurgency over the Windsor
framework the Northern Ireland protocol
with it on the vine he cut a lonely
figure you know very few people followed
him into the dissenting Lobby and yet in
one Fell Swoop last night he's managed
to Breathe new life into himself into
Boris Johnson and I think look I I can't
see a parliamentary or political return
in the short term and probably not ever
but being no doubt Johnson is on the war
path he remains a powerful Communicator
he is his own best megaphone you know he
has one song to play and that was I was
robbed but more importantly he's free to
say now what he likes when he likes
without consequence or accountability
and just one final thing Anna he's very
good at this you know he's at his best
when he's an Insurgent you know he was
famous for lobbing rocks across the
Thames when he was mayor at Cameron and
Osborne he will now I expect do exactly
the same with Richie sunac only sort of
rather than rocks he appears prepared to
sort of love the political equivalent of
live ordinance and I think where that
ends is anybody's guess okay well no
doubt we will be talking about it again
in future then uh will Warden
fascinating to get your insights thanks
very much indeed for talking to us this
morning we appreciate it thanks Anna
take care
so time to have another look through the
papers this morning here with me to
review them are the journalist and
author Jasmine Alibi Brown and CEO of
international marketing Partners Alison
Stewart Alan so welcome back to both of
you we dealt with um a lot of the front
pages in the last hour dominated of
course by Boris Johnson's resignation
but uh we're delving a little bit deeper
now and um Yasmine you've picked out a
story I think is actually on the front
page is it no it's not on the front page
anyway it's focusing on the um
the resignation honors of Boris Johnson
that would otherwise probably have made
the front pages today and this is in the
guardian their take on that list that
emerged yesterday afternoon
hello it's really important this because
he's not the first and he won't be the
last
to use the honor System in ways that
really aren't acceptable in a real
working democracy handing honors to Pals
to found funders it's been going on a
long time but he has taken it to another
level if you look at the list
you know a lot of the people who were
involved in the party gate scandals
um I remember the bring your own bottle
party with Martin Reynolds he gets um
some sir or something and then there's
pretty Patel
um Jacob Reese Smog and it you know the
Lords is not a private members club for
the powerful for a prime minister in
power and that's how he's used it Sean
Bailey who failed to win the mayoral
London Maryland election and we saw a
photo of him and about 20 people
partying during lockdown
so it's a pretty
abysmal and shocking list I have to say
even for a system which in my view is
very corrupt okay and there will no
doubt be lots of discussions still about
um some of those honors but as you say
and but there's discussion quite often
when when these resignation honors do
come out whoever the leader is and
Alison take us to the telegraph page
seven
um a lot of focus in recent weeks on AI
there seems to be growing concern about
it and this focuses on on whether or not
regulation could keep up absolutely and
this is typically the case you know as
Industries evolve uh legislation and
legislators are behind the curve uh
mostly because of the machination of law
making uh it takes a while to get laws
formulated and approved and passed and
implemented uh so uh Tom tugenhatt who
is the security minister was addressing
a conference uh in the last couple of
days and was talking about a culture
change is needed to be able to deal with
advancing technology and deal with it
really quickly the challenge however is
the window within which you have to deal
with this advanced technology is very
very short indeed now he's suggesting we
have two years I think and all the
experts who have been talking about AI
think that it's much less than two years
uh you know recently we had major
resignations from Google and from other
leading Tech firms these experts have
been working on AI and they have
resigned as a message as a signal to say
if we don't regulate this if we don't
control this we are potentially uh
ending our own Survival as a species on
this planet which sounds melodramatic
but it's it's actually very likely that
you know human many human deaths will
result because of unchecked Ai and how
it's applied uh and uh that the
challenge for British Parliament is they
better do something quickly but they
can't they don't work quickly that's
that's the challenge I know a challenge
of governments Around The World Isn't it
as well and Yasmine take us back to to
politics
um inside the eye this time and and this
focuses on reactions um I think is it
just in the party certainly political
reactions to Boris Johnson's resignation
and and so what's the eye telling us
about how it has gone down
well as ever he's dividing the nation
there are those who love him and support
him and some of them
um have also been honored for their
loyalty
um and others who say Good Riddance and
it's it here's a Marmite character
though I'm I must say at this point when
we know so much more
because it's been investigated that
there are still people out there
he was standing up for him in in the
political circles Jacob Reese smog
pretty Patel Michael Fabric and
um obviously in the dean Doris who's
leaving
um they think that they kind of This was
um he was he had a golden touch and uh
his you know that people have been
horrible to him but I remember the
reading some time ago his school teacher
in a report said this boy does not
like taking responsibility or understand
the consequences of his actions or
something like that and I think that
little boy is still there he really is
okay aggrieved that anybody decided to
check up on him